كيف هذا النشاط الذي نراه الآن
من كاميرتك بصوت مجسم ليس بعيدًا
عن غزة كيف هذا النشاط أه الذي
نراه مقارنة بما رأيناه
خلال
الليالي الماضية الذئب خلال الليالي القليلة الماضية
لم يكن كما كان  مكثفة إلى هذا الحد،
لم نشاهد هذا المستوى من الإضاءة، لقد رأينا
أحيانًا قنابل مضيئة
وسمعنا انفجارات شديدة ولكن عندما أنظر
هناك صاروخ آخر غير متأكد من نوع
الصاروخ الذي كان يهطل
من السماء حرفيًا أه ويؤثر على
أطلق وميضًا ساطعًا يخرج منه،
ويبدو أن هذه صواريخ أصغر قليلاً
ولكن المنطقة هنا التي
تضاء بواسطة القنابل المضيئة أكبر بكثير
مما رأيناه مؤخرًا، لقد رأيت للتو
وميضًا يخرج من هناك ورأيت للتو
صاروخًا آخر يسقط و  ومن المحتمل أن يكون التأثير على
الأرض هو الطريقة التي
قد يكون بها مسار هذا الصاروخ
قادمًا من طائرة هليكوبتر، لكن
ليس من الممكن بالنسبة لنا أن نقول ذلك بدقة في
الوقت الحالي ولكن هناك تركيز واضح
للنيران هنا، هذه القوة النارية
والإضاءة التي يتم شراؤها  يبدو على
حافة ما أقدر أنه
مدينة غزة، وأعتقد أنني رأيت للتو صاروخًا
يطير بالفعل إلى اليمين خارج غزة،
وسنراقب إلى اليمين باتجاه أشود
لنرى ما إذا كان هناك أي
اعتراضات من القبة الحديدية ولكن
كان هناك نيران تتبع حمراء انطلقت حرفيًا
من غزة إلى اليمين والتي
عادة من تجربتنا هنا كان
صاروخًا يخرج من غزة لا
أرى أي اعتراضات في الأعلى،
أسمع اعتراضات أرى ومضات
من الصواريخ الاعتراضية  تم إطلاق النار،
فبينما يحدث هذا هنا، فمن
الواضح لي من موقفي الآن
أن حماس أو إحدى الجماعات الأخرى
تطلق الصواريخ من غزة حتى أثناء
تعرضها لهذه النيران الكثيفة الآن،
إذا سمعت صاروخين على الأقل  انفجارات
من اعتراض القبة الحديدية أه
درع صاروخي من أه الأنظمة التي تقع
إلى الشمال منا قليلا هنا
تعترض تلك الصواريخ التي تطير خارج
المدينة أه ما يخبرنا به هذا الآن
هو أن المعركة ح تمر
بلحظة شديدة حيث تحاول القوات  يتعاملون مع
حماس أثناء محاولتهم الحصول على الإضاءة، فهم
يحاولون استخدام هذا الضوء للوصول إلى
طريق أكثر أمانًا في القتال مع حماس،
حماس بالطبع وقادة جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
يتحدثون عن هذا، حماس تقاتل على
أراضيها وقد نصبت أفخاخًا
تعرف أين تقع  الأنفاق التي تعرفها
تعرف كيف يمكنها أن تحاول قيادة قوات جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
وإغرائهم إلى حي معين
حتى يتمكنوا من إطلاق النار
عليهم، كل هذه الإضاءة هنا
ستمنح جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي أه القوات على الأرض
رؤية أفضل للتهديدات التي
تنتظرهم  لن يخفف
منهم بشكل كامل ولكنها محاولة لهم
يبدو أنه قادر في هذه اللحظة على
اختراق بعض الأحياء أم أنه
حتى قبل 15 دقيقة كنا في
ظلام دامس أه أنت ترى فقط
وميضًا آخر من الضوء
الأرض هناك كما لو أن شيئًا ما قد
انفجر، أنا أشاهد نظامًا صاروخيًا آخر
في أجزاء متعددة، الصاروخ الثاني
ينزل إلى المدينة،
هذه النار مركزة جدًا،
صاروخ آخر سقط للتو، أرى
القوس، آثار التتبع  بعد ذلك،
هناك كمية مكثفة جدًا من
القوة النارية التي تنهمر على هذا
الموقع المحصور هنا، ومن
المستغرب تقريبًا أن حماس كانت قادرة على
إطلاق الصواريخ هناك، وأرى ومضات
تتجه نحو الشمال وهو تلميح لي
بأن  تم إطلاق صواريخ اعتراضية من
القبة الحديدية هناك مرة أخرى، ومن المحتمل أن يعترض
صاروخ آخر صاروخًا آخر، لكنك
ترى القنابل المضيئة في
كثير من الأحيان عندما نشاهد القنابل المضيئة
التي يتم إسقاطها فوق غزة،
سترى شعلة واحدة تسقط قنبلتين مضيئة
وربما ثلاثة  وسوف يسقطون
وسيذهب إلى الظلام، هذا مختلف، هذا
توهج بعد توهج بعد توهج
يضيء هذه المنطقة الآن
لتعلم أننا ننظر إلى ربما 15
دقيقة الآن ذئب